about two years ago her son Brandon
wanted to start making his own money cuz
they live pretty poor they he only makes
about 18 or 19k a year and he bought he
actually handw wrotes letters and
there's his neighborhood next to the
apartment they live in he went around
Distributing these handwritten letters
hey I'll mow your lawn for $40 give me a
call and he started getting calls he
borrowed my lawn mower for a while
started making his own money he bought
his own and a little while later the
money he had in his drawer from working
his mom took it saying well no what do
you mean I didn't know you had this much
money we got bills to pay at this point
I was trying to say why would you steal
from him what are you doing and she said
two things one you can't steal from your
kid everything that his is mine she has
character issues you can blame it on
your family tree if you want to but just
because um misbehavior is part of your
family heritage doesn't mean that it's a
good thing it doesn't make it okay